et pour parler de la situation ensuite
vous également au danemark nous
retrouvons en direct de malmö richard st
paul minier vous êtes éducateur à
l'école française de copenhague alors
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
entendu parler de la situation en suède
mais également au danemark vous êtes
d'ailleurs bloqué puisque la danemark a
fermé ses frontières
quelle est actuellement la situation
bonjour alors là c'est la situation
c'est que comme je ne peux pas
travailler d'abord puisque les écoles
sont fermées
j'ai dû rester en suède donc je suis
confiné en suède par manque de travail
mais je pourrais aller travailler au
danemark passer la frontière puisque
j'ai un numéro de sécurité sociale
danois et suédois donc je peux passer
d'un pays à l'autre
sur présentation de la carte jaune la
carte cpr danoise
on parle souvent des pays scandinaves
comme des pays modèles dans la
discipline est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une différence entre le danemark et la
suède
concernant la gestion de cette pandémie
mondiale alors il ya eu mieux il ya une
différence puisque la suède a pas fermer
ses écoles affirmé que ces universités
par exemple dans les supermarchés a
particulièrement de de stress ou de
rayons vides
c'est comme tous les jours les gens vont
se balader
dès qu'il fait beau ils sont sur les
promenades et puis en ville je pense que
c'est un peu moins stressé que du coup
au danemark où quand la première
ministre a annoncé la fermeture des
écoles la semaine dernière les
supermarchés se sont remplis très très
tôt le matin sur copenhague
vous parlez d'une situation quasi
normale en suède est ce que le
finalement les suédois n'ont pas
conscience encore de la dangerosité du
coronavirus à cause peut-être justement
du d'un nombre assez
pas très élevé par rapport aux cas de
contamination ou de décès alors il ya
quand même vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure il ya sept morts et puis il ya
en été ce matin en 181 quelques
contaminés il ya un cas de guérison je
pense que les deux pays sont différents
sa boîte la scandinavie c'est quand même
il ya quand même des différences de
fonctionnement de géographie de
population vous dire que les gens sont
pas stressés c'est difficile moi
personnellement j'essaie de rester chez
moi donc je vais pas trop à la rencontre
des gens en ce moment mais c'est vrai
que quand je vais me balader
je suis dans la campagne pour sur le
bord de mer qu il ya plein de gens qui
se baladent qui font du vélo avec les
enfants et bien qu'il fait beau c'est
comme d'habitude donc j'ai pas le temps
j'ai pas un sentiment de stress au
niveau suédois mais j'ai vu discuter
avec des amis danois régulièrement qui
vont supermarché qui me disait parlant
que hier qu'il n'y avait pas
particulièrement de stress je pense que
par contre les suédois comme les danois
sont des peuples plus disciplinés à
l'écouté de leurs gouvernements qui ont
confiance dans leur gouvernement et qui
préfère respecter les règles en suède il
n'y a pas de règle de confinement donc
je pense que les suédois sont
relativement moins continuer chez eux
que les danois très bien en tout cas
merci beaucoup monsieur richard st paul
milliers d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je vous rappelle que vous êtes éducateur
à l'école française de camponac